welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season 2 is coming to an
end in the upcoming week we don't know
how it will end we know how they're
feeling which I think is the most
important thing but we don't know the
what the when or the where now it's time
to get back to answering those questions
this is the sneak peek where we take the
temperature of whatever we're watching
while we head into the next episode or
look into the next week of nerdom
joining me to talk about what will
happen in the Loki season 2 finale is
mod Garrett hello mod hello yes the who
is here amazing we feel very
self-important uh it's kind of lovely
though that we've got the whole team
assembled that's what Marvel likes to do
best and I find that once you've
assembled the team only good things
happen that's right and maybe the finale
will expand that team to include some
other cameos from the Marvel Universe
and by the way for everyone watching if
you want to hear us talk about what
really happened at the end of this
episode and how Loki was able to command
control of his own destiny uh check out
the break room for our inside Marvel
discussion on all of that we had some
really great thoughts coming out of this
episode on thday also had an epic singal
which I think the episode is worth
watching just for that just for that
just for that uh hopefully hopefully um
seal doesn't find us and um make us take
yeah he's going to send Heidi out to
beat us up are they still together
they're not I'm so glad You' got an
entertainment reporter sitting next to
you yeah I know like 20 years ago heid I
still thinking Heidi Heidi from Project
Runway era and be like you imagine you
know so much about Marvel that it makes
up for it you can't know about okay I
can't I I really can't I got to make
room you know on the plate okay so
Loki's motivation this season has been
to save the TVA and prevent multiversal
War he keeps bringing that up until
Sylvie called him out on that
in episode 5 but how will this season
end will he succeed or will we get more
of an All Is Lost moment to set up
future Marvel St stories is this going
to be an ending in Victory or an ending
in defeat is it going to be a New Hope
ending or an Empire Strikes Back ending
I actually feel like this episode The
penultimate episode five had that
Devastation that feeling of loss already
um I think we've got a glimpse of what
it looks like where every single branch
is collapsing on itself every person
that you know and love is turning into
spaghetti uh so we're kind of getting
that dusting moment again and that sense
of loss uh and that sense of you know if
you don't fix it now it's all done so I
find I I feel like we've had the ending
on a bad note for this one which is
going to set up for a Saves the Day in
the finale I hope that's that's yeah I
think structurally that's exactly the
case it takes a long time to edit and to
export these pieces of video content so
while I wait I go on ipsos iay to answer
some quick survey questions to earn
points and redeem them for Amazon gift
cards IPOs Si say lets you earn extra
cash through gift cards and rewards just
by taking part in in research and
answering a few simple questions there's
a ton of different gift cards to choose
from but lately my go-to's just been an
Amazon card it's easy and convenient to
earn a card switch tabs and then pick
out free stuff for myself the surveys on
ipsos IA are quick easy and tailored to
my interest so it never gets boring I do
them whenever I have a few minutes to
kill if you use public transit it's a
total Game Changer I upgraded my
downtime and you can to just click the
link in the description to start earning
rewards with ipsos I say today before we
continue talking be sure to check out
nerd. shop where you can get and grab
the latest and greatest new Rockstar
gear I'm wearing our OB inspired we're
all gonna die shirt show us it we're all
gonna die we're all gonna die screenshot
that it's the best uh so you can also
check out a new line of merch from uh
the Marvels it's a flurin shirt it's
it's flurin awesome fling good yeah
fling lurking good um support the
channel check out our great merch
options over at nerd r. shop and don't
forget to subscribe to all three
channels in the new rockstars Network
new rockstars the Deep dive and the
breakroom oh by the way we got a crazy
week ahead of us on New rockstars on
Thursday we're going to have an ending
explain video for the Marvels don't
worry the the packaging isn't going to
spoil it but you know for those of us
who are going to be watching it Thursday
I think we're going to need some answers
so we're going to have a video talk
about whatever the post credit scene
ends up being I haven't seen the movie
yet or in the ending of the movie we're
just going to talk about it in that
video on Thursday Friday is going to be
our Loki finale breakdown Saturday is
going to be our breakdown of the Marvel
film all the Easter eggs in the movie uh
and we're going to have a whole bunch of
other videos covering those properties
but also videos on Invincible on Rick
and Morty whatever the new episode of
those are are coming out so um there's a
lot but if that's not enough come hang
out with us in person at our upcoming
Los Angeles live show on November 16th
Thursday tickets are on sale now and the
link is in the description I Love
Invincible by the way can I say that
it's so good Invincible is so good uh
don't sleep on this show it it I mean I
don't want to say it's the best thing on
TV when it comes to like superhero
fiction but it might it's up there I
like the realistic thing it's almost
like undoing What U Marvel has done
which is Heroes will save the day all
the time it's like what um the boys and
gen V are doing it's it's how
catastrophic humans can be or you know
superpowered people can be um with with
and taking it to like a like the
Superman concept of uh what if like
Krypton didn't get destroyed and like
kryptonians were still call izing the
Galaxy like how horrifying that would be
where screwed yes yeah yeah yeah hey so
speaking of um at the end of season 1 we
get a SE a tease for season two do you
think we are going to get a tease for
season 3 even though Marvel has not
announced a season 3 of Loki do you
think that we are likely to continue
this series in particular I think we
need a season 3 of Loki I don't know if
that season needs um all the elements of
that are currently in the show but this
show has been so good we don't need it
right away we don't need like 20
episodes of it but just say Loki will
return because it is like it's been the
best thing uh or one of the best things
from Marvel phase 4 and Phase 5 Tod
agree I actually think it's the best one
I mean I I'm waiting for Deadpool 3 I
have a soft spot in my heart for that
but I think that what they're doing with
this show and how season 2 I it's
tracking to be better than season 1 for
me at the moment oh wow yeah episode
four just is some of the best television
that I've seen from Marvel uh in recent
memory so I'd love a season 3 I will say
though we are kind of tidying up the
story line the tva's purpose and the
fact that it's no longer once they sort
of like Rectify that and then the sacred
timeline's intact I mean is season 3
going to be Kang Dynasty or is it like
well we notified you of what the TVA is
it's so much bigger than anything
anything else that we've experienced
with Marvel so far and I love the fact
that you know the Infinity Stones are in
a drawer like that's how minimized
everything that we've seen so far has
been and so once this is all fixed it's
like it didn't happen and then we can go
back to all the other Marvel
storytelling knowing that there's an
entity out there kind of like stitching
up the timeline should it need it but
won't kind of like interact or interject
again yeah you know I don't think we
need um we need a he remains or a Kang
in a Loki season 3 um I think it's been
really set it up at the end of season
one it set up at the end of season one
and I think we should see a future Kang
Dynasty story that Loki appears in but I
don't view them as like mortal enemies
that like one needs the other I think
it's been really fun to see Victor
timley and I do think we need to see
like the impact of uh of everything he
REM remains has done what the TVA has
done in the future of Marvel in Deadpool
3 and Avengers King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars for sure but I think a
future season we're talking like 2026
maybe a future season of Loki imagine a
version of Loki that just continues to
explore the Loki character as we knew it
in Loki season 1 episode 1 through five
where it's just a relationship between
two different Loki variants we could
meet few other Loki variants that affect
Loki in a specific way we could continue
to explore the Norse mythological
elements of Loki and his relationship
with Thor with Odin with frga you know
there's a lot there's a lot to explore
there with just the Loki character
so much more than that it's like that's
I feel like that part of Loki is almost
done because the Loki character himself
Tom heston's Loki has changed so much
the first like four episodes of season
one like he's kind of realizing that
escaping or controlling or manipulating
doesn't really serve it because it is so
much bigger than him and then season two
you recognize that he's lonely he wants
his friends he wants love like he wants
he's just changed so much as a character
that I think him being the god of
mischief and being the trickster God has
almost taken a back seat because saving
this timeline has become his agenda and
again I think almost season 2 has
ignored the elephant in the room which
is the end of season 1 killing Kang had
this ridiculous Loom effect like it has
completely fractured the timeline but
it's also introduced the line that he
said it's like I'm the nice one I'm the
good one and now you've unlocked all the
other variants of me you're screwed I
think you can't set up something that
big and have him in the uh
Quantum um cut scene end end scene you
know you have him in all these little
parts and then just completely Nick that
whole uh setup the setup's been huge
well don't misunderstand me mind I'm not
saying to go back to what Loki was in
the infinity Saga I'm done with that too
the character has evolved but I think
what is most interesting about the
character is seeing him mix with the
members of the TVA and the
infrastructure of the TVA to me it's an
amazing workplace Douglas Adams Sci-Fi
show and that's what I like I like
seeing stuff like Alcatraz and DB Cooper
and the way that this TVA interacts with
history and Loki's involvement with that
and with you're describing Doctor Who
honestly I think I just need to watch
Doctor Who this is kind of a doctor who
sort of thing where it's like time is
just a bit wibbly wobbly timey Wy you
know yeah and what I I don't need Kang
to be the looming Shadow over that show
I think there are other multiversal
threats there are other multiversal
complications that Loki can create for
himself what I want is Marvel's Doctor
Who Marvel's Rick and Morty and that's
what for the most part what I've Loved
most about Loki uh and yeah I don't need
Loki as someone who's just like playing
the god of mischief and I love how
episode five sets him up as the god of
stories as the currently that is
currently a status of Marvel Comics can
you tell me more about the God of
stories cuz that was popping up a lot in
the comics and I am not a comic reader
uh I am a nerd though I really love to
hear what this Evolution could look like
and what you know about the God of
stories yeah so um it seems like there's
a couple big polls from Marvel Comics
specifically the 2014 run the agent of
Asgard where uh the character of B15 in
this episode established is Varity
Willis uh she was Dr Willis and then if
you look in the in the credit sequence
her her name badge photocopy when they
have like the Sarah hin credit screen
they show her name as ver Willis son of
Roger Willis or daughter of Roger Willis
the Willis family in this comic run is
established to be the the caretakers of
the casket of ancient Winters which uh
was an Easter egg that uh Kenneth bran
out put in the original Marvel um Thor
movie that's the one that like Loki
opens up and it freezes you that's just
one of the relics in Odin's Vault
doesn't really seem to have major
importance in the MCU going forward
though uh but also a special magic ring
the family needed to take care of this
ring and uh Varity Willis when she was
like a toddler ate the ring and it they
took it to the hospital but they found
it had dissolved in her stomach but it
left her the Ring's uh Power is that it
gives you the ability it's kind of like
a lasso of Truth you can see when
someone's bullshitting you now she has
that power now just innately in her body
um so that kind of makes her a natural
counterpart to Loki and this agent of
Asgard run where they run into each
other when they're speed dating uh and
they just kind of this amazing
relationship where Varity is able to
just like keep Loki in check and just
because Loki's whole thing as the god of
Mischief uh is like he can lie he can
deceive anyone and then in the president
Loki run he's like that's my thing I'm
good at lying that's what's going to
make me a good president so uh Loki's
status now at least in the current ERA
of the Marvel Comics is no longer the
god of Mischief but really the god of
stories and that's how he's able to get
ahead of it is he's just a good
Storyteller he's a like he's able to
embrace fiction uh and kind of Define
his own narrative and just spin a good
yarn uh and I think that is what uh I
think that's what this episode is now
hinting at is he's uh his glorious
purpose as uh has been kind of undefined
because it's not just enough to say that
you're trying to prevent allout War uh
but there's something to be said for
fiction like a a Storyteller he begins
the episode saying oh you're a writer
we're doomed and now by the end of the
episode he Embraces the idea of of
telling controlling one's own narrative
and being a playwright an author
actually that's a fantastic segue to
this other question that I have Obi
calling Loki a character from one of his
books in this episode um do you think
this is figurative or literal do you
think that Doug is seriously has written
a version of the god of stories in his
sci-fi has he been dreaming about the
variance that we saw in the Multiverse
of Madness what are your thoughts oo
dreaming as we learned in Multiverse of
Madness is seen into the eyes of your
multiversal self that is a rule in the
MCU uh I I thought about this a lot mod
while I was writing the breakdown and
the more I thought about well did Loki
kind is it a Stranger Than Fiction
scenario and Loki is a character in ad
Doug's fiction that has come to life if
I actually extrapolate that and play
that out I don't like where that is
going because I hate I hate The Twist of
oh it was all in someone's mind like the
the Tommy Westfall ending of s elsewhere
famously characterized all the events in
the St elswhere series a popular medical
drama the kind of show in the 80s uh
that had Denzel in it like the ending
the big twist ending was that the the
kid who was established as an autistic
child earlier in the run is shaking a
snow globe and all of the St Elsewhere
hospitals contain in the snow globe and
he is imagining all these characters
like they're his puppets and it was just
kind of a twist ending that they tried
it was bold and it did not work for the
tone of what s El was trying to do do If
This Were a Twilight Zone series maybe
and maybe that could kind of work in
Loki I just it it takes away too much I
agree completely I I just I I then I
think too many Marvel fans will just be
like wait what I think I just don't like
that idea I like the idea that he's a
writer and then it's just similar to his
writings and that's why he's like kind
of the perfect figure to partner with
Loki going forward I have two thoughts
on this my first one is I don't like um
how Marvel introduced huge
groundbreaking impacting events likes um
the fact that there are Scrolls on Earth
and their body shape shifters and anyone
could be one and then all of a sudden it
was fixed and we can go back to normal
except every now and then a scroll will
pop up from time to time and not impact
uh anything anymore uh and I worry that
that's going to sort of like tie this up
where it's like no time and space
doesn't nothing exist it was all written
and it was just a book from this guy's
imagination and so you could go back and
not be impacted by that story at all I
wouldn't like that but I will say that
when I um when we are introduced to ad
Doug I kind of saw him as the connective
tissue between um science which is what
or Boris is known for he's written the
TVA handbook he's the one who's um
invented the loom he's the one who's so
brilliant and he's got his science down
even the fact that he is a scientist in
this particular brand uh sorry branched
timeline makes a lot of sense but this
fiction part of it the the name of the
episode science SL fiction you had to
spend a disbelief of the hard science
enough to use something bigger than that
bigger than numbers and the stats and
the facts to go into a place that
doesn't exist in science so to speak so
you kind of had to have both of them
mesh together which is or Boris um being
a scientist and now a science fiction
writer I think that that's all it was it
like he was that missing piece the
connective tissue to go to that place
that's that's not on the map so to speak
yeah I think that's uh a really great
point mod I think this is a meta message
from the writers that they're not
scientists that they're fiction writers
so the answers to these questions cannot
be found in science textbooks that those
science textbooks inspired their writing
and their understanding of the
Multiverse and their un and to me that
is almost a declaration that we're not
doing what Avengers endgame did where
they brought in theoretical physicists
to consult on the Multiverse Theory and
Branch timeline Theory we're doing what
dramaturgs fiction writers do when they
try to depict time travel and unify
everything on a single timeline that
uses a bootstrap Paradox in
predestination and this is like no
filmmaker is more obsessed with time
than Christopher Nolan and every time he
does time travel in a movie it is the
same type of time travel where weird
events that happen in the First Act of
the film are unexplained until the
character gets further down into the
second and third Act of the movie and
you realize that those events that they
saw were themselves or one of their
friends time traveling at some point
further down the path and looping back
on them to make reality as weird as it
was back then that is a specific type of
time travel structure and storytelling
that is only done by fiction writers and
filmmakers because they believe and
they're right that this is the mo most
cathartic way to tell time travel in
terms of the character's point of view
because they realize that they don't
have to worry as much that life is just
going to take care of itself but they
are destined to make the right choice
this is what Harry Potter does and I was
to say shout out to prisoner vavan yeah
same thing it's the same thing and and
it works I mean I've looked into these
stories way too much so I can kind of
see it coming but I got to admit it
works every freaking time I've have seen
Interstellar probably 20 times and I
still get teary when I realize when he's
like it was us we built this tesser act
murf murf's the answer and a lot of
people poo poo that they roll their eyes
at it but it works on most people yes I
agree and I also like the fact that that
this H it's it's told Crystal Clear in
this episode like science is the where
the what um you know that's that's the
science I want the all of those sort of
things and the fact that they're going
stop being so concerned about the where
and the whats um and even the wise let's
go take it back to fiction which is who
it's storytelling it is about his story
and who is sharing this and whose
Journey we are on so I kind of like that
as well in it yeah do you think we're
going to learn that Loki cre the TVA
that he was really the uh the spark that
gave by him giving the book to ad Doug
that that was really the origin point of
it all well what were they trying to say
initially that his um imploding event
that his Nexus event uh was obtaining
the tessera right and that's why he had
to be pulled into the TVA because he was
never supposed to have that kind of
power maybe that's all BS maybe it was
there was always this point in his
sacred timeline where he is Branched off
because it is only him that could
facilitate the TVA to have that
relationship with Mobius to bring things
back uh for his particular variant to
kill Kang like maybe he is the center
point of all of this um and he was so
consumed with the first half of his life
with you know conquering midgard and
having power but we realize that he's
now the vessel between something that's
so much more than that I think so I
think so M I think like they took a what
a moment that like fans of the infinity
Saga felt was so critical from Avengers
cuz PE Marvel fans look at Avengers
endgame as like every beat of that movie
is Gospel and I'm gonna say something
controversial Avengers endgame was a
very very good movie but it was not a
perfect film and it was really cobbled
together and it was a miracle that they
pulled it off and it was as fun as it
was but as a film I'm not I'm not saying
Martin scors is the only person who can
make good movies but it is a very very
very weird film structurally and not all
of it works independently and I think 20
years from now we're going to look back
and people are going to be like that is
the most profitable movie of all time
okay um I think it's more of a sign of
how Victorious Marvel Studios has been
over their history is the reason why it
was buildup there just Decades of
buildup that we've just loved so much
and I think it's a gargantuan task that
the filmmakers pulled off to get all
those characters together and to get any
kind of meaning out of it I think is
incredible I would never be able to do
that so I applaud that
but I think just that moment of Loki
disappearing from the events of the
Battle of New York was crazy and weird
and they didn't have they didn't know
what was going to come out from the
other side of that and I think the Loki
writers and producers have brilliantly
taken that moment and just blown away
from it and made it just from the
episode one made the tesser act so
depowered and not important anymore but
I think what this season has done is it
has said that the most powerful thing
throughout all of history that you can
do is give someone a book and say read
this and use this thank you that is that
is the uh extraterrestrials or fifth
dimensional beings giving primordial
humans the monolith in in Stanley kubric
that is God touching Adam's finger to
give someone a book to give someone
knowledge you are blessing them with
power and knowledge and they can do with
that and that can be a good thing it
could be a very dangerous thing putting
a Bible in someone's hands can be a very
beautiful thing it can also be a very
destructive thing giving mind comp can
be something very destructive giving
some of the Communist Manifesto can be
very beautiful and enlightening but
either way giving someone a book is a
very powerful thing to do and with great
power comes great responsibility yeah I
wonder where that came from the big the
big Crux of episode 5 though uh what was
so important is that he was putting the
team back together um and I do think
that I loved that particular part um
even though time has been pretty funky
this season are we going to get a reveal
do you think that that it's Loki who
pulled every TVA agent from their lives
on the timeline and forced them to work
at the tvas this is a big question that
I had because um the first half of this
season like the reason why Brad wolf and
his character took like a huge step up
is because we wanted to learn who these
characters were before the TVA now Mo
Mobius never wanted to acknowledge it at
all uh we learned that Ren Slayer was
our school principal um so we had an
idea we learned that B15 was desperate
to know who she was uh before it all we
learned in season one that Sylvie can
actually go into those memories um and
she discovered that they were variant
that they were all variant to begin with
but is Loki the one who has hand plucked
his team is this another uh loop that
has happened where he's seen them at
this part of the journey where the
team's already been established but he
has to go through to then recruit them
again honestly at this point I think
that might be where they're going um I
think by accident or just by this like
quick necessity I mean really it was you
could say a kind of Fate he didn't
intentionally go to Alcatraz or to uh
Cleveland Ohio or to that New York
hospital um he was pulled there he
brought himself in a way uh and I think
that's going to be the implication that
Loki really created the TV as we know it
um their memories are going to get wiped
they're not going to attribute it to him
um and I I think Loki I think that
really the timeline of it is it all kind
of like a self-justified bootstrap
Paradox not of course but Loki inspired
OB at this point in the loop uh OB did a
lot of the groundwork and I think built
the architecture of it uh but I think it
was meant to do something better
something more wholesome bring the
Multiverse together and just kind of
monitor it uh but then Kang came in
there at the end of his War took control
of it staged a coup and then turn it
into this this authoritarian regime of
only one timeline so it really does come
down to the TVA handbook because or
Boris wrote that but it was Ren Slayer
who delivered it to Victor timley who
then was able to take over with that VAR
you know what I mean like it's it's
interesting that this piece of
information um yeah how that how that's
such a catalyst and how important that
is to to Kang to Ren Slayer to M mines
to aoris all of that kind of stuff I do
have a question though with the
assembling of these TV variants and that
is Loki slipping into branched streams
branched timelines to collect these
variants this is not necessarily the
sacred timeline so the team that he's
constructing are now on branched
timelines if he's collecting branched
variants for the team does that is that
going to conflict anything is there a
sacred timeline anymore because we kind
of came to the end of time it's a good
question yeah I think there is no sacred
timeline anymore and I don't think there
ever should have been a sacred timeline
um I think right now this season's done
a good job identifying when things are
on the sacred timeline when things are
branches I think in this case they're
all branches because in order for them
to have been variant working at the TVA
they must have been categorized as
having been part of a branch timeline so
that's that's why they revert to it but
I think what we're going to see mod is
we're going to see just a
recategorization of everything and
everything that we can considered the
branch timeline is
just existence you know you just are
part of a Multiverse and then instead of
Branch timeline as because branch makes
it sound like kids table like lesser
than you know yeah um so rather than
branches as a uh as a relation to a
trunk and an inferior everything is just
going to have a numerical categorization
that is not 616 that'll just be you know
different numbers and what you're
describing is chaos the entire point of
the TVA was to prune the branches to
have a consistent sacred timeline to
stop the chaos that happened completely
you've just discussed the motivation of
Kang I don't think that is so bad he's
just trying to find order in this
constructed chaos that's happening but I
think chaos is nature I think order is
but you need a balance between the two
uhhuh yeah I think Eric Martin described
this as a balance as a fight between
order chaos yeah and then Ren Slayer
said she wanted order and then
implicitly when Sylvie came in in
episode 3 and wiped everything off the
floor it was like she represents chaos
and I think uh he remains is represented
order I think Miss minut has represented
order and I think Loki is kind of caught
in between I think right now by trying
to M trying to carry out he remains
Legacy he's he's uh holding up the
poster for order I think sylv is trying
to uh preach to him the merits of chaos
chaos and that was the end of that was
season 1's finale that was exactly that
we need to kill him so that we get
choice we get Freedom back and he's like
don't do that because it will'll fall
into chaos and she's kind of like that's
entirely the point so you're right syvia
does represent chaos and fascinatingly
we've seen Loki evolve into choosing
chaos and being the cause of chaos to
actually seeing the product of order and
the the the benefits of needing order
and structure again beautiful heat check
before we go into the finale
um are we going to be satisfied on
Thursday night if it is just a
self-contained knot with only the
characters do we need any kind of tease
for Deadpool 3 or anything beyond that
do we need the idea that the TVA has
arrested or a new version of the TV has
arrested someone named Wade Wilson or um
that would be actually really wonderful
I would personally love that because I
love that kind of fan service and I love
I I'd love a beach to be able to tie
this into the universe a little bit
better we didn't get that with secret
Invasion so much um it was very
self-contained they kind of took care of
all of it so that they can continue the
story without it being impacted at all
and I think that when we it it would be
very very easy to have this be very
self-contained and it's like cool we
fixed it so then we're back to order and
none of it mattered anyway uh it is a
likeliness of that would happen I would
love to see this bleed out a little bit
more into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
one because we want progression of
Storytelling and everything that we've
just seen in this season should actually
matter and two I want Marvel to make me
care about the Marvels because at the
moment I don't I think it may be a
little too late for that I think the
Marvels didn't really know what kind of
press campaign they wanted to run they
changed it in the final weeks and
started to get a bit more like no it's
not going to be its own self-contained
wacky adventure with these three women
it's also going to set up major Stakes
for the MCU because I think they got
scared when they saw early ticket sales
I honestly am cautiously optimistic
based off of the scenes that they've
released I'm like this pretty fun don't
you think that them being tied into the
finale of this would be the perfect
marketing strategy because this is
coming out at the release of the Marvels
so if we see something that's impacted
in the finale that would put my bum in a
seat to the Marvels so fast if it's
going to have a direct impact or it's
going to be a catapult into the story
that we're about to see but maybe mod I
just think like if they were really
planning on doing that they would have
had Loki and a month before the Marvels
came out instead of on release night
because by doing that they're going to
force people to stay home and watch Loki
and not go to the movie theater and I
think they want people to be their
opening weekend of the Marvels and they
audien is make that decision like a week
or two ahead of time like I don't think
they're going to put down Disney plus to
be like I gotta go to AMC right now but
it's possible I mean they've done crazy
like that before right they had um
Hawkeye was coming out as Spider-Man no
way home was coming out and Spider-Man
no way home had Daredevil in it Hawkeye
revealed um Kingpin in it so like yeah I
mean that makes sense because that's New
York Centric they're all exist it's like
you know just because it's only in
Hell's Kitchen doesn't mean he's not
going to pop up a few blocks down the
road you know that's right I so I like
the fact that they weren't containing
and sectionalizing New York as a whole
but I think for here I always think of
it as like the TVA is looking down on
all the timelines here so it's almost a
God complex funnily enough it's Loki who
is a God I would like to be able to see
that space and whatever's happening up
there or between bouncing between the
timelines they can see it from the you
know their Podium and season one they
had like um coordinates of Hala of
xandar of Morag season two has not
mentioned the wider Galaxy at all no
because it's it's fixing what's in front
of us in a way the timeline I don't know
if I can say that season 2's been better
than season one for me just because I
really love the void and we haven't gone
to the void yet I assume we're going to
go there in the finale um but man I
still really love this show it's been
almost as good as season one and that's
saying something for where Marvel is at
right now you know this has been a blast
episode four for me like I've never been
more happy watching a show than with
episode 4 so finale stick The Landing if
you can get it even close to episode 4
that would be great uh also hearing the
feedback from everyone they loved this
episode they loved episode 5 they
thought it was amazing I actually will
change my appreciation for episode five
based on the finale okay we then we're
going to have to see what happens in the
finale I'm super excited it's going to
be huge week for Marvel obviously we'll
leave it there for this episode of the
sneak peek be sure to follow new
rockstars on all social media follow mod
Garrett mod Garrett someone asked
because I kept talking about how the TVA
guide book is so important we should
read more books and science fiction is
great I hosted sci-fi fantasy book club
someone said how do I join uh if you
look up uh
discord.gg slod Garrett you can actually
join an online book club there we're
reading great books this month
absolutely join that that sounds a lot
of fun uh what I am reading right now is
uh Joanna Robinson Dave Gonzalez and uh
Gavin Edwards amazing MCU the reign of
Marvel Studios I'm almost done with it
it is such a good book about the history
of marel and why things are the way they
are in Marvel is all laid out in this
book that is is it on the table in your
office cuz I saw it opened yeah we're
all we're I we're all reading it now at
the new rockar office I'm like this is
required reading of everyone here you
have to read it it's so good oh oh
John's bringing it in right now it's
amazing uh and uh Joanna Dave and Gavin
just do something that like we've
desperately needed in the MCU and anyone
following the MCU it's just some kind of
fact-based Journalism and Reporting and
actual sources is rather than people
just uh creating Anonymous Reddit
accounts and Twitter accounts and saying
I'm hearing per my
sources this is this is the real this is
the real truth and it answers a lot of
questions we've been having for years
and years and years great job to them uh
follow mods book club and join that book
club get on get on the book reading list
um and uh thank you all for supporting
us at new rockstars and we'll see you
next week bye
[Music]
everybody
now